i mean that's your party trick exactly
i'm hoping that i'll be inspired by this
game to last as long as possible against
magnus age 10 on the app yes because 100
moves would be a lot of money for
traffic oh that would be amazing
um one thing that really impresses me
about david is that um he can play 400
moves and you know he's he's always said
in the past that he likes to play when
he's a bit hungry because that makes him
really hungry so you must be famished by
the time you finish that game but how do
you keep your energy going you know and
i struggle these days but when i was
younger i would often maybe okay i'd
have like a bowl of cereal for breakfast
and then i wouldn't eat until the game
finishes at eight nine pm so i don't
know i just and then i would eat like a
kink i'd have a feast yeah but uh yeah i
don't recommend it it's uh i think these
top players the top players for a reason
snacking up as we often see and is ding
abandoning his winning chances
it looks like the game has finally been
drawn on move 110. was it a repetition
or um
did he actually offer a draw we see
magnus calls him shaking in his